hello my name is daniel corning it's a
big pleasure for me to be talking today
here at year one
year one and uh it's actually my very
first uh talk in person four i don't
know like two or three years during the
pandemics i've been talking at nvidia
gtc or dc west and so on but all of that
was done you know from the comfort of my
home zoom and so on and you know
so please be forgiving a bit
and
uh
the pulp is a conversation in our
research lab
and at depaul we do a lot of things like
applied research fundamental research
and we build products all around
conversational ea
and before we'll talk about how you can
actually build ai assistant using our
technology i would like to start with
the question why
i'm 36 year old guy and
when i was very very young to me
just having technology was enough reason
to be excited
but today why is very important
yeah assistants are not a new idea
uh charles babbage created his
differential engine in the 19th century
and uh vani var bush
wrote his fantastic uh
article as we may think in 1945 july in
the scientific american envisioning how
technology could augment human
intelligence
but
the very first big steps towards
augmented human intelligence started in
xeric spark in 1970s where we've got the
precursor to personal computer
and uh the approach to augmented human
intelligence was simple we used a
desktop metaphor
which allowed people to transfer
learning from their physical analog
world of folders and files to computer
and this is a very much of well-known
fact if you work in computer science
industry and
if you haven't read the book dealers of
lighting
i really really recommend you to read it
it's a fantastic book and it pictures
the early story of xerox park and it's a
very very exciting read
however the last known fact about direct
spark is
uh that they also coined the term called
ubiquitous computing mark weiser was the
chief scientist and knight is uh there
at the time he
wrote also in scientific american
article about that and the idea was that
computers can become
pervasive they can work in different
places have different form factors and
you would transition from one computer
to another
and a human would not even see the
computer in a way they would just
interact it with different computers and
uh will be able to pick up the work they
started on one computer or another
computer and so on division was really
big and darker started an invisible
computer initiative in 90s
and in 2000 a lot of things happened
that continued this foray into the idea
of augmenting human intelligence
uh bill gates a founder of microsoft in
1992 and comdex created a
made a talk information at your
fingertips
where he envisioned that windows would
have intelligent operating system and
file system inside it that all
applications would work on top of it and
put data in it the file system would be
object relational so different
applications would be able to access
information from each other building one
personal knowledge graph
and thus uh because of these connections
we could get a lot of
insight from this kind of data
it was a very complicated story uh
perhaps the most known approach uh
microsoft took in the direction and
there were multiple efforts all failed
was microsoft wienerfest it was deemed
to be part of windows longhorn which
eventually became windows vista are
quite hated by the way
they've done a lot of progress over this
direction at the same time darpa started
their project called
personal assistance that learns paul
and a sister project of it kayla
cognitive assistant notes and organizers
and it was practically similar to
binafest in a way that conducted data
from different data sources and allowed
people uh to get different kinds of
insights so imagine you come to a
meeting like today
and this assistant would prepare you
everything that you need to know to be
prepared for today's talk
about personal assistance so like i
would not have to prepare the slide deck
because the system would prepare the
athletic for you
another example was that you have a me
tank and after the meeting it would send
you meeting notes there are lots of
startups today that do this kind of
stuff but those kind of ideas were
implemented by kayla project at darpa uh
two decades ago there were some startups
emerged from it like a smart desktop
i mean it was called smart desktop so
it's super hard to find an internet
because when you look up for smart
desktop you can find anything but not
not the startup
who tried to build their team at
university somewhere in oregon i believe
they tried to build a system that could
organize information by projects
they were acquired and a company was
acquired and company was acquired at the
end that ended up in vmware and vmware
then
canceled the whole thing i also spent
like five years building this kind of
system as my own the universe
and it's a very complicated story to
build this kind of assistant
however something happened in late 90s
eric corbin's through microsoft research
built kind of systems the notification
platform and priorities
and priorities was the system that was
able to understand when it is
controllers one is right to interrupt
person
a notification platform was designed
to deliver notifications to whatever
device you want today will have
notifications iphone android windows mac
whatever
but back then this didn't exist so the
perhaps the first patents were provided
to microsoft research and eric corvitz
so you kind of see here in this picture
but these are different kinds of devices
like the desktop at home desktop at work
and a mobile device and a pager by the
way in a voicemail because i mean a hike
times you know some of you didn't exist
at the time when this slider was made uh
this this slider not the whole thing
and uh then a big thing happened
there was a huge transition from a smart
desktop to a ui system device
and the first child of kalo was siri
it was built at sri and then it was
acquired by apple
and um then we've got a lot of ai
systems like that so like alexa and
google assistant which
was created like 2016 2017
uh microsoft build their cortana and so
on and so forth
and uh those devices
are different
in fact it's very similar to what mark
weizer at xerox park defined at the
1990s
we have a since everywhere so i have a
smartwatch here
and i have a phone
and here i have earpods by amazon where
alex is inside and somewhere in my
backpack there should be ar glasses
created by musics and those er glasses
they also actually run android and they
also have alexa inside and google
assistant as well so
we've got this pervasiveness and
invisible computing here so i can use
these watches and they will have a
assistant inside them
that's crazy story
however
they lost something
we have yeah systems on the desktop so
when we we married the idea of smart
desktop things in in early 2000s and the
ai systems of 2010s but they are stupid
cortana is mostly that google was
sitting super hot in stone windows it's
an unofficial client and online lex
exists
and the other thing is ai systems is
expected to see and hear
like in
space odyssey
but they don't so to speak
so
with that said 99 that nine percent of
ai assistance is still left unlocked
and that's a huge problem we still don't
know how to build their assistance we
know multiple approaches but nobody
built the whole thing
fortunately amazon created the challenge
alex surprise sociable grand challenge
where
uh
academic teams from all around the world
participate in building social bots that
can talk different kind of topics and
sustain conversation for 20 minutes and
get the rating four out of five
the thing is nobody managed to beat any
of these metrics one team in elixir
price three um
hit three that eight
the other team alex surprise four
managed to maintain 40 minute talk not
bad but then the other metric was really
down
and we were fortunate to participate
couple of times under that surprise
challenge so we know how hot it is
and for us
uh when we look at the power of at how
you can build conversational ai systems
we don't think that it's just a
conversationally i think like siri or
it's a smart desktop like something we
had in the early 2000s but a combination
of them
combined with a system that can do tasks
on top of your on on behalf of you
uh that can connect to people when it
needs to handle the operators that can
have multiple user experiences like
voice and text and visual and
multi-modality and at last but not least
be reachable through different kinds of
channels and devices
and at the public we work on many things
like here so we spent more than four
years building our platform here i'm not
going to go into the details but we'll
look at the slightly torn uh they will
shift
so the approach we took was
neurosymbolic we don't want to adjust
neural networks and you don't want just
to use a symbol capacity you want to
combine both so for example if you want
to extract sentiment
uh in the conversation uh then we use
neural networks when we want to have
tight control the conversation we want
to have symbolic approach
and that's how our platform was born
so conceptually we have an agent here
this is a conversational agent not the
smart desktop kind of engine
it has lots of different annotators that
extract features from user utterance
when user in talks to the system and
then multiple skills that generate a
hypothesis of what the system could
reply back to the user and then combine
it together with different nlp models
and skills and so on it creates an
entire ai assistant
now this is architecture of how the
actual thing works this is the dream
social bought perhaps the most
sophisticated we think we've built at
the palo it's participated in alexa
price 4 and that's how the platform
basically looks like when you utilize
all the features of it
so when the user says something we
extract different features we transform
oral speech into region by using
sentence segmentation
we rewrite the sentence and use
reference resolution so with he she they
and so on were replaced by the names
of people in organizations we extract
entities we identify sentiment emotion
toxicity other things then define useful
facts based on the entities formed and
so on and so forth and once all this
information is obtained by the platform
at the annotations level we send it to
skill selector
now if any of you have ever used alexa
or google assistant you know that when
you want to interact with a third party
skill you have to know know the name of
the scale to invoke it in our case you
don't
skill selector is designed to build such
a way that it can intelligently decide
which skill has to be invoked uh to
provide the response back to the user so
this happens invisible to the users like
invisible computing your razer computer
computer is computing back to mark laser
unfortunately he died in 1999 so it's
not possible to talk to him today but i
think he would be happy to know that we
are building the future he once
envisioned
now the skills can be different
uh they can be written in a yamakop
language which releases was rewritten in
early 2000s and they got to
go through their turing test they can be
template-based they can be general
models like for example blenderbot from
pearlite folks at facebook
we have a very beautiful python based
dsl the main specific language for
writing directories that could be
retrievable like convert reddit the data
set is no longer available uh the
original one is closed but you can use
the skills we have in our uh repository
so it's very easy to use
once those processes have been generated
uh they are sent to candidate annotators
here which basically help us to filter
out the response that might hurt user
you might see something inappropriate or
you might be not in topic that might be
not engaging and we care about all those
things and we want the system to filter
out wrong responses
then the skill set sorry the response
letter makes a decision what of those
responses should go
as a response back to the user
and in some cases we might combine
multiple responses or maybe even produce
something else
and on the next turn we go through
response annotations we just help us to
better understand what the system has
replied to during the previous term so
that's the architecture
the key things here is that this
asynchronous pipeline
some of the components might depend on
each other but they all can run in
parallel in general that means that you
can scale it a
lot and um we have like 40 skills
implemented to 20 different annotators
and we use the depos library which
became quite
popular over the last four years
as a foundation for nlp models don't
want to go big into this thing but
usually you feel happy when you show
good numbers to people and say like hey
this is pretty much useful
um that's not like we say that but the
people say that
okay so that's a huge uh intro
uh
let's go into the platform itself so in
the heart of the apartment it said
before the agent the pull-up agent as i
said before it's a synchronous um
mechanism for writing pipe sorry
asynchronous pipelines mechanisms it
allows you to run multiple components in
parallel they can be dependent on each
other and so on and have managed to
sustain seven erps during correct
surprise competition and we calculate
that can can support up to 100 thousand
rps given that we use a solid
infrastructure like kubernetes and aws
for example
and uh from logical perspective you have
lots of uh services described in docker
compose file
and then we have the pipeline
pipeline called json which basically
explains the whole pipeline as a set of
services depending on each other and the
mechanism how you can approach those
servers like http or unit uh unix
sockets or tcp sockets
and so on
and then there is something called
formatters one of those formatter is you
transform dialog state into a
readable form for the component and the
other one is obtaining the response from
the component and provides it back into
meaningful way to the agent
ah this is example of skill you might
not be able to read it so you can just
go to dream deposit and talk and we'll
see how it works
the key thing here is that we build the
response election selector which makes
um
it possible to pick the right skill
relevant uh to the current conversation
based on this algorithm again i don't
want to dick a lot into this i can read
our technical report for example
uh but the thing is you can plug new
components into the system without
having to rewrite response lecture which
is important here as a dialogue state is
based on common metadata we have
utterances like human and bot and so on
then we have human profile blood profile
but profile can be
pre-populated before the conversation
while human profile can be populated
during the conversation so user might
say that their favorite city is moscow
or
or new york city or seattle or something
like that and we will record it and put
it as a human profile
okay
and just
a few more things uh the whole stack is
a bit bigger than the dream so at the
bottom we have the pulp library which
bill has a mechanism for building uh
pipelines synchronous pipelines for
building nlp models we have a few
engines one is for building uh
neurosymbolic skills using dialog trees
and generic models then we have an
engine for running multiscary acids and
a simple engine for running single skill
ai systems of better set chatbots then
we have the platform itself the default
dream which allows you to build things
like collects itself
and outsole framework that allows you to
build simple chat bots and those have
their tools for their flow designers and
also it's available today and you can
build
skills using it
and we are also building dream builder
which will allow you to visually
construct your only assistant
okay fine that's the theory you needed
to know to be perfected tutorial
so tutorial
um
i i work carefully on this slide so we
had to fix a few bucks during this last
week before today so i can watch that
everything shown in the slides works as
it is arbitraged on the slides
so at first you can obviously go to
dream that they follow that again just
talk to default distribution the
distribution is very simple idea in
linux you have multiple distributions
like ubuntu and fedora and debian and so
on
in our case it's the same so we grab
different kinds of skills and annotators
and combine together they form a
distribution that can be focused on for
example chemical cheat chat or ai
assistant or a simple chat bot something
like that
and the largest one dream that i showed
you earlier today uh is deployed uh to
dream that depauw data and you can just
talk to it
you don't need anything to begin with it
then you can go to uh web tools in your
favorite browser and see actually that
holy cow you don't see anything here i'm
sorry about that
uh but you can see in the slides and in
the video
uh that uh when the system responds to
it says which skill was the active one
i guess you can show other hypotheses as
well
now
one more step let's go to postman you
can go to
709.depaul.ai and send a very simple
payload which basically consists of the
user id and the text you want to send
and it will give you a reply with
obviously the same metadata you have
seen in the browser
finally time to try in the console so
the for console will go to
github.com your 4k clone it to your pc
run default distribution dream
distribution with proxy so the whole
thing is huge
it takes about
25 gigs of gpu ram so i'm still waiting
for my three
uh 1390 to come from united states to
here one here so that they could
actually run the whole thing with my
machine i already have 1080 so to
together they should run
the whole thing and it requires i think
45 gigs of ram so it's a huge thing so
for com for convenience we
made the dream distributions api
available for everyone through proxy so
we can just run it through proxy but if
you want to run on your own machine in
your data center if you're lucky or rich
or boss usually if you you know
you can have a surrounding machine and
then you can talk to it through the
console
and console very easy you type username
you start talking to it and every time
you will see this huge output of all the
components that have done processing of
your user utterance
here is a very small hello yeah one here
uh
but the thing is it's pretty convenient
to talk to it this way but i find it not
convenient i
uh we also have a api slash chat for our
platform i will show it and i will show
if i element another uh
ip address and port
uh and i use different tabs for
different components in the terminal uh
to to debug them separately
anyways
so now that you understood how it looks
like and how we can interact with the
system let's try to build one
you will need some nix based operating
system or you can run wso2 in windows uh
you'll need key docker docker compose
and so on
sorry
uh and you will also need our common
language uh sorry uh command line
interface tools ringtones
which actually allow you to build your
own distribution put necessary
components into the settlement run the
whole thing in your machine
so first you will need to uh install
bring tools next to the clone of the
dream repository and uh
then you can just run uh run those tools
uh you might need to add that
that local slash b into your past if you
haven't done that before
and then just run twos without anything
if you see this output you're happy if
not complain to us on issues and we'll
fix it
i tried on different machines in
different virtual machines a clear one
not clear one it worked so it should
after that uh you can go to our
readme.md and
figure out what distribution want to
start from and make a list of components
and in case of this demo i decided to
build a very simple multi-sql assistant
with three skills intent responder
brothers can
download for chit chat intend responder
is a very simple like faq model sort of
and weather skill i mean like who
doesn't like sorry who doesn't like
weather they all like to show the sample
as this is the best way of showing task
oriented system
um
and the thing is when you will pick the
components even if you didn't specify
which component is dependent our tools
will automatically pick them up
so that's how it looks like you say
dream twos new ds you call the name of
the new distribution we specify which
one you want to derive from you pick the
components you want and then it will
happily say that create a new dream
distribution
after that you need to run it and
running it very much the same as when
you run the default one from proxy this
time you've got a couple of changes one
is that you have the name of your custom
distribution and the second is dev.yaml
where some local components will appear
then you can talk the same way as before
through the console but you have to
specify the name of the distribution
okay
and uh you can talk the same way to the
distribution as you could before
now that you understood how to build
this whole thing so you didn't add
anything custom you just cropped a few
components from the system set build my
distribution have run it they say okay
it works so let's figure out what's
going on
with the data so uh you can talk to it
through postman
and it will be on port 4242 the same
payload as you said before no https just
http and you will say get the same
response
i highly recommend you to use some sort
of uh editor with syntax highlighting so
it could understand the output easily i
use notepad plus plus it has plugins for
parsing json and throwing object
structure very useful
so the output is simple you have a
dialog id which is important to know you
have active scale you have the all the
hypothesis with the anna patients and so
on with the hypothesis response and the
confidence of the system
and when you want to see the whole
dialogue what's going on it just grab
the dialogue from the previous slide and
put it to the slashing pad slash daleks
and you will get the full structure
here's i've uploaded it in the notepad
plus plus here is the visualization of
the structure pretty much the same as
you as i showed you in the slide before
and you can like expand utterances to
see what was set in the conversation
this is very short conversation hi hello
and
i could click on annotations to see how
all the components in the platform have
processed like hi there so obviously
there is no new intent there is no
special sentence segmentation because
like hi there just one phrase and there
are no entities inside but like it's
very simple example
i might go to hypothermia will be the
only one hypothesis because the further
skill doesn't have anything to say when
you say hi there
so that's how you can work
with the debug output of the platform
now
before we will go next uh we will talk
about how to build task oriented skills
or chit chat skills using our dff the
fifth style flow framework it has a
beautiful python dsl we coined it last
summer it's a super beautiful thing
we've looked at things from
from folks uh
in just the atm uh who created uh their
uh dsl they looked at uh what other
teams did in different elect surprise
competitions and i believe you coined
the bad thing
um so the idea is very simple you have a
script and a script you have node and
you have transition to the other node
very simple transitions can be different
the beauty here is that
conditions for transitions can be based
not only regular expressions and so on
but also conditions can be based on the
output of the annotators so you can say
user sent me this but the sentiment was
negative i have to cheer them up
or it can
specify specific entity and we can do
something based on the temperature
so
uh when you grab something like dsl
without annotators you will be very much
limited is what you can do and you have
to enter processing in here but when you
have an entire platform you can just use
all those annotations for free
the other concept is all those uh nodes
are organized into flows and you can
transition from one flow to another
based on different conditions now all of
you will say you know this is just a
tree like they are much older than your
mother is probably my mom was born in
1954 so and i think eliza was born
something around that time
so you'll need to be wrong but
not really
the thing is uh you can plug generate
models anywhere in the system so you
don't have to re uh use just if the
house logic to make transitions uh
between things
anyway let's take a look at a complete
example uh here's a weather skill so go
back to console you can type username
and ask about words in new york city
we can do the same but in postman so i
say tell me whether
and the system will specify ask me to
specify which city i care about
i will say new york city and will
provide me with a response
how does it work
so go to the dialogue uh you will see
that the system used name tempted
recognition to detect new york city's
location and
uh look and location in entity detection
entity detection is more smart way to
detect entities than there
and they were combined
and this time we've got two responses uh
the dow gpt is a general model it always
has response to anything so it said like
what city even though it doesn't know
how to answer the question what the
weather is in new york city because not
connected to anything and the second one
is i was killed different by the skill
and the system effectively picked the
right skill here automatically on behalf
of you i didn't change anything as you
can see
so let's work and see how the
multi-skill uh mechanism works
okay so now i can look at code uh
you open this code from the root of your
local
dream repository you'll go to skills and
to differ faster skills and go to
scenario open main.pi file
and again i'm sorry you don't see most
of the details of our beautiful language
here but
basically you have a start note you have
condition to transition to other places
one of the places uh where we can tell
forest cost if there is entity inside
and the second case is when uh we don't
know exact location we have to make a
location request to the user
so
we don't have to go linear we can go
anywhere we want it jump between flows
and so on okay
to edit things we've built dev designer
it's extension face code it's draw your
base and uh it looks like this so you
can right click on the file open in um
the designer and we'll see this
beautiful
more or less beautiful thing where i can
click on a note and it will show you
suggestions so what to do next i don't
want to go into details right now but
uh
if you add a new skill to the system we
can also edit it in the same designer so
here's an example we use a dream tools
new dfab
we call uh default means a new g5 skill
so we didn't decide to put slow word d5
scale then we specify the name of the
skill we specify which
uh
which distribution we want to add the
too
and then it will ask also to create a
formatter in one of the four files there
i specified which file is here to put
formatter don't care about right now uh
at some point we will just make this
redundant work so this step will not
require the second step
you can do the same you can open a vs
code blah blah blah and go to your skill
go to main pi and edit it
using right click on main pi choose open
vs specified df designer and you will
see this visual interface
so blue nodes are now both answers
yellow are human answers so your user
can reply differently so we have
multiple yellow nodes coming after the
blue node
but also can respond differently but we
show that online code
and you can use the recommendations so
you click on a note you click on show
suggestions right now the button is here
uh it's in menu
double click on suggestion
this is the suggestion you double click
on it
you name it
and
specify that would be specification of
the name of the suggestion click save
and uh you will get the next couple the
next big conversation step so it's very
easy
and then you obviously can talk to it
uh we also have support for knowledge
graphs and slots that experimental
functionality will have a more advanced
slot feeling technology but it's also
very simple you can just say that you
want to extract the entities of specific
type
you
say the type of the entities you say
where to put it the name of the slot and
then you can use the slot later on in
the conversation
so that about it that concludes the talk
uh i put a lot of links right here we
also have a qr code here that provides
you even more links to all of the things
you need to build your multisql uei
assistant
and in general i want to encourage you
to build your own ai systems using our
platform it's
not that young we've released version
one uh back in december of last year we
battle tested it during collector price
three on the left surprise four
uh it has multiple components and
you can plug anything specific
you want to use the system as well
and visit you can basically build your
own alexa or google assistant and run it
in your data center
and it's open source it's on the apache
to the tool so we can easily use it and
like most of the code of written python
you can work in python to build the
whole thing anything you want
and um
it's super user friendly as much as i
can say and before that i worked on a
little bit i worked on ai city and in
one eastern european country
um i would say back then it would take
four or five years of investment for the
company to build multi-security
assistance for their audience and then
it would be impossible to use it by
anyone else in this case we've done this
job for you
we're giving this thing out for free so
just rub it use it and try to build your
motor scary assistance we're looking
forward to do it and now if i still have
time for questions i will be happy to
address any of them
um vladimir here in the first row
[Music]
first of all the new thanks a lot
i really respect the power since you
published your first uh pre-trained
models
uh
yeah i have a question about the the
actually the two questions the first was
about the reference resolution that you
mentioned yep so it's as far as i know
it's not about only the
uh
pronouns you can don't have the pronoun
so do you solve this problem
like okay like that i'm in london what
is the weather
so you need to slot field i don't think
that we support this case exactly but we
support things for people and
organizations
okay and and and the following question
is that uh do you actually need for
every skill this annotator because in
some skills it's actually
uh solved by the feeding the to the
neural net the context so like gpg you
mentioned for chit chat for dqa for some
other skills so uh on a teachers are
design i mean the whole thing is
designed in such a way that
the information you feed to a skill
depends on the formatter promoter
basically maps information from the
dialect state to a skill so if the skill
doesn't need this information you don't
have to provide it to the skill because
that would minimize the network cost
um
that said
you can use it for prompting as uh
tokens and so on
okay yeah that's why i'm asking because
in your presentation that was before the
intent recognizer as far as i understand
okay and the second question is about
the intent recognizer itself uh you got
the structure like as far as understand
lots of binary classificators yeah yeah
instead of
multi-class classification we actually
have multi-class uh classification as
well for sentiment for toxicity for
topics and so on we have one uh
one classic layer with seven different
tasks
this helps us a lot to save on resources
yeah and my question uh is that if you
grow the number of the skills from 40
for let's say 10 uh
yeah yeah
and thousands
wouldn't be the problem because you will
accumulate the
errors
like
vertically
i think that the key part of
what we do at the power is we do applied
research from the amount of research and
we build products
and as i said before 99.9
is not unlocked yet so
once we will face a situation with 10
000 we will figure out the new problems
and then we will look for the answers
right now we have like 40 skills mining
at the same time they work yeah okay ask
because we got the same problem and
it was the bottleneck actually of the
system because the dialogue policy works
with the multiple of classifications for
intent recognition and there was always
the problems with
negative right in our case we use
all different kinds of annotations to
make the decision
and for different skills we have to
invoke different uh kinds of annotations
so
system is pretty much scalable when you
want to have scenario-driven things we
actually don't even use intents
everywhere sometimes they are not
required to do that kind of thing
yeah cool thank you
excellent question uh so until very
recently i would say english only
then we decided to support russian uh
then we decided to have a multi-language
support multilingual models and that's a
stupid thing because you start talking
to it in english and it's an answer in
chinese uh you start talking to it in
chinese and answers you in armenian for
example
and you start talk to an armenian and i
don't know it
figure out it's no klingon and nobody in
my team talks cling on so we're still
tuning it
but in general we have a multi-language
model uh multi-language distribution but
we're still working it
it's a crazy thing you know i mean
it's not easy yeah like a very long time
ago i wanted to
uh when i was starting a relationship
with my first girlfriend i was enjoying
the fact that we can speak different
languages we talk in russian in the
morning and we can speak in english
but this
our model is not as fun as i would
describe it in personal relationships
it can be confusing it knows way more
languages than i do
okay
second second
yeah microphone do you have already uh
your own um
language models or
or
you
use only
retrain the open source models like we
are one of the providers of open source
brand models uh lots of them actually
some of them are state-of-the-art models
so we have like ruby earth case
conversational it has 1.3 million
downloads and hugging faces our model i
don't know what the hell is going on
with this model others are a little bit
less popular but yeah we do they have
models for these for open the main
question answering uh
lots of things actually yeah they have
distilled models they have full models
and so on uh do you plan to publish new
pre-trained models on hiking quests for
russian i yeah yeah we actually do it we
actually
only
i think we have about uh 16 models or
something like that publishing for
hugging face and the more models will
have like right now we are cooking a new
named entity recognition model that
supports ordinal dates and times and so
on but it's also uncased and supports
two languages at the same time which is
super useful when you want to do it for
ei assistant which usually uses asr and
asr obviously gives you on case
information so and we're obviously going
to publish it as well it will also part
about the power library wonder toe that
we ship in september
thank you
thank you very much for all of you